in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion for October 8, on which we commemorate,
our righteous mother, Belaya, the penitent. On the 8th of the month,
we celebrate the memory of our holy mother, Belaya, the repentant harlot.
Saint Belaya lived at Antioch in the second half of the 5th century,
where she was the best known harlot of that great city.
Her devotion to dancing and unchased pleasures made her a great fortune
that she spent entirely on adorning her body with costly raiment
and voluptuous perfumes in order to attract new victims into her net.
She had many slaves and servants who ascorted her whenever,
seated in a luxurious chariot she went about the city.
One day, the Archbishop of Antioch invited Nonus, the holy bishop of Odessa,
to address some of his bishops in the Church of St. Julian.
For he was a man of inspired utterance, able to bring those who heard him
to repentance and love of virtue.
It so happened that Belaya, with her usual retinue,
passed by the doors of the Church, near where Nonus was speaking.
While the other bishops and pious folk averted their eyes,
Nonus looked upon the woman and wept, saying to them,
Whoa unto us, lazy and careless people,
who will have to give an account at the day of judgment
for not having been as zealous and careful to please God
as this poor woman has been to adorn her body for fleeting pleasure.
And he prayed fervently to the Lord for her conversion.
Belaya was among those who listened to Nonus
preached on the Holy Gospel at divine service the next day.
What he said about the last judgment and everlasting punishment
struck her like a rapier thrust to the heart and awoke in her
a love for the heavenly bridegroom which is the only true love.
On her return to her palace, she wrote to the holy bishop
asking him to receive her and not to scorn her for her depravity.
If he were a true disciple of him who came to call not the righteous
but sinners to repentance.
Nonus answered that if she had truly resolved to repent
she should come to church and confess her offenses
before the whole congregation of clergy and people.
Belaya seized the opportunity and hastened to the church,
forgetful of all her pride and pomp.
She threw herself at the feet of the bishop and begged him
for regeneration to eternal life in holy baptism,
lest the devil and habit draw her back again to sinful ways.
The whole city of Antioch rejoiced at the baptism of Belaya,
a nun called Romana, undertook to guide her first steps
in spiritual warfare and the life of repentance.
And so, by prayer and the sign of the cross,
Belaya overcame the temptations to return to her sinful life
that were not slow to make their appearance.
Some days after her baptism, she gave away all her wealth
to the poor and freed her slaves.
Then, free of every worldly tie and clad like a poor woman
in rough clothing, she departed for the Holy Land,
unknown to all, to lead the ascetic life on the mount of olives.
She remained for many years in a little cell,
struggling each day against the passions that were deeply rooted in her body
and devoting all the care she had once taken over her outward appearance
to adorning her soul for everlasting life.
Despite her solitary life, Belaya's valiant spiritual struggle
became well known to the other ascetics of Palestine.
They did not know, however, that she was, in fact, a woman.
When the Holy Penitent gave up her soul in peace to God,
all the monks thereabouts gathered to venerate her holy relics
and they gave great glory to God when a disciple of Nonus
told them the true story of Belaya's life.
For it teaches all who are engulfed in the darkness of sin,
not to despair, but to set out courageously on the road of repentance.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord,
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.